[Musique]
des radiés en crue des routes submergées
la tempête tropicale berg ita a
particulièrement frappé les hauts de
l'ouest ainsi que le sud de l'île
environ 600 mm d'eau sont tombés en 24
heures sur cette zone
beaucoup de pluie en fait tous les
radiers submersible son été submergés
avec beaucoup d'allusions donc il faut
tous se curer tout ça on a eu beaucoup
d'éboulis ausy est donc voilà on gère ça
y est quand même avec cet épisode
pluvieux on a pas mal d'arbres qui sont
tombés avec le sol détrempé et donc
voilà on va pomper tout ça au fur et à
mesure mais pour assurer la sécurité des
usagers
le mauvais temps passe et les agents des
unités territoriales des routes sont à
pied d'oeuvre pour rétablir les axes de
circulation sur la rd 13 route hubert
delisle
l'accès est impraticable sur près de 800
mètres les spécialistes reconnaissent le
site pour démarrer les travaux de purge
alors que ya des cordistes qui vont
s'équiper en amour et qui vont descendre
en emmenant avec eux tout ce qui peut
partir tout ce qui est posée qui est
qu'ils pourraient tomber prochainement
les cordistes s'engouffre difficilement
dans la végétation pour trouver les
départs des éboulis une fois cordes et
les travaux de purge peuvent commencer
quand on voit le laroche se fissurer
tout ça demande qu'à tomber donc là en
ce moment on est en pleine période de
purge avec des routes coupées à la
circulation ont fait le maximum pour
pouvoir les livrer avant la reprise des
transports scolaires donc lundi prochain
des routes départementales pour le
moment impraticable
au vu de ces effondrements la préfecture
ainsi engagé la procédure de classement
en catastrophe naturelle pour une
dizaine de communes sur le territoire
[Musique]